bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi
siamo in questo primissimo blog
anzi no secondo il primo luogo è stato
primo video di fa vige tv allora scusate
il file iniziale non siamo neanche
partiti i 10 secondi o velato benvenuti
a questo secondo blog del canale vi
volevo fare gli auguri a tutti quanti
non ho avuto l'opportunità di farlo
purtroppo perché non ho fatto vino in
questi giorni è infatti l'argomento
principale video sarebbe questo che non
ho potuto fare vita in questi giorni
perché ovviamente tutti voi siete in
vacanza immagino abbia tecnico è passato
il natale con i vostri familiari e anche
io essendo un essere umano e avendo
anche una famiglia perché non sono un
extraterrestre
anche se quindi i capelli si ci vado
vicino ad essere un extraterrestre sì
diciamo ho passato il natale con i
parenti come giusto che sia quindi non
più fare video quindi mi dispiace non
aver fatto uscire nessun video in questi
giorni ma da adesso si diparte
normalmente adesso che ci sono anche le
vacanze tranquilli ma parte capodanno
ovviamente le sue ci sono le vacanze
iniziano tranquillamente a far video
metterò video almeno uno ogni due giorni
sicuro forse anche un po di più visto
che ci sono le vacanze di mezzo non so
comunque vedremo
niente volevo augurarvi buone vacanze a
tutti e farvi sapere che adesso si
riparte tranquillamente per quelli di
voi che non lo sanno tutti i miei blog
da adesso in avanti perché diciamo i
blogger io facevo su tsg adesso li farò
su parigi e tv perché quindi sul tsg
facevo soltanto io allora davis in
avanti blog che faro su fa vj tv saranno
strutturati in questo modo diciamo
all'inizio faccio vedere una fan art
ovvero un disegno che mi è stato fatto
da qualcuno di voi è veramente si ultimi
dato che non faccio un blog da secoli
omicron anche quando fatto l'ultimo
me ne sono arrivate diverse di fan art e
ringrazio tutti quelli che me l'hanno
mandata sono veramente tutte bellissime
e diciamo ogni blog che faccio faccio
vedere sempre un disegno fatto da
qualcuno quindi se voi ve la sentite di
riuscire a farmi un disegno su un tema
qualsiasi horror che volete un
videogioco che tratto comunque
semplicemente disegnarmi se il disegno
cari non lo metto in un blog
lo faccio sempre in ogni blog è il
disegno di oggi è questo qui purtroppo
ragazzi non mi ricordo chi è che ha
fatto questo disegno si sta guardando
questo video l'autore anzi l'autrice
perché mi ricordo che una ragazza dopo
che tutti i disegni che mi avete mandato
sono stati fatti tutti da ragazze ce n'è
stato solo uno di un ragazzo che adesso
farò vedere anche quello perché sennò
tutti di tema puoi vedere soltanto i
disegni delle ragazze no perché cesto
partito preso che le ragazze sono più
brava di segnare non è vero c'è lo
spazio anche per i ragazzi quindi per
questo video blog farò un'eccezione e vi
faccio vedere anche un disegno fatto da
un ragazzo eccolo qua
come potete vedere anche noi ragazzi
siamo in grado di disegnare come mai
tutti quanti dite che le ragazze sono
più brave non è vero potete vedere
ammirare i tratti lineamenti di questo
disegno che secondo me sono fantastici
questo natale ho ricevuto questo
braccialetto qui che è una specie di
braccialetto cm non dovrebbe essere
l'utilità
però diciamo che non lo so se devo fare
un disegno tecnico in
alla veloce l'ostacolo a braccio e
iniziò a matita sul foglio perfetto
invece il regalo che mi sono fatto io un
regalo mi sono fatto da solo ho preso
delle un headset dell'app latronico
spero di aver detto nella marca giusta e
diciamo che quando giocherai videogames
horror impersonerà al cento per cento il
personaggio protagonista perché sento
con quelle la si sente tutto
praticamente e tutto a discapito del mio
cuore perché ovviamente gli infarti che
prendo il sun round sono moltiplicati
quindi diciamo dovrò a fare commentari
col defibrillatore di fianco perché
finora ho dovuto fare commenta di con
sta roba che più che microfono mi sembra
una collana o un collare per cani e
niente tuttofare commentari con sarò a
bahia veramente la qualità è molto ma
molto bassa rispetto alle le cuffie
normali quindi da adesso in avanti
sentirete la mia voce molto più chiara
molto più normale invece che con sta
roba qui e diciamo che dovrò prepararmi
psicologicamente perché gli infatti che
apprendo con quelle cuffie sono diciamo
di tutt'altro stampo ecco volevo
puntualizzare un qualcosa di abbastanza
importante che mi è stato fatto notare
da uno di voi e me lo sono scritto qui
perché diciamo eve è una critica e le
critiche le prendo sempre bene diciamo
non me la prendo con quelli che me le
scrivono se sono costruttive anzi ne
sono ancora
mi sono scritto il nome e la critica
allora stefano greco mi scrive valigie
come mai il tuo background e così
orribile e spoglio non c'è nulla non
potresti aggiornarlo allora c'è una
particolarità su questo fatto allora il
background che ho adesso è
effettivamente background che definitivo
soltanto che voi non vedete ancora il
banner lo vedono anch'io perché devo
diventare partner appena diventerò
partner automaticamente si sbloccherà il
banner e vedrete tutto mi pare che
adesso si legge soltanto una micro
scritta mascini ma partner ma non si
vede non si vede per niente il banner si
vede solo questa micro scritta perché
devo diventare ancora partner dovrei
diventarlo verso il primo gennaio più o
meno quando mi arrivano le cuffie niente
volevo parlarvi un pochettino dei
progetti che ho allora innanzitutto
vi ringrazio per il successo che sta
avendo il canale nonostante molti di voi
mi conoscano già comunque diciamo tutti
gli iscritti che ho adesso sul canale
sono tutti attivi e vi ringrazio
tantissimo i progetti che ho in futuro
sono gli stessi che avevo promesso ad
essere gaming ovvero il prossimo
episodio se tutto va bene prossimo
episodio del canale che vedrete tra
pochi giorni dovrebbe essere il primo
episodio di penombra che mi state
chiedendo da dal da quest'estate mi pare
all'inizio di quest'estate quindi da
giugno luglio giù di lì e non l'ho più
fatto perché è per problemi non
continuato sul psg però penombra che
avevo fatto sul the chair and gaming era
penombra black blog non sono anche se si
pronuncia così sto facendo un file e
norme ma non importa
ma ho deciso di iniziare dal primo
capitolo ovvero il primo capitoli
penombra che è penombra overture quindi
riniziano completamente da capo un gioco
nuovo e penombra black bloc che quello
che avevo fatto nel primo che l'episodio
che ho già fatto sarebbe se quel di
quello che sto per fare e tra pochi
giorni quindi quando finirò questo
questo l'ex play vedrò se vi è piaciuto
rifare anche quello di continuare quello
che avevo già iniziato sulle scene
gaming comunque in sintesi sto per
iniziare penombra overture questo per
quanto riguarda l'oro per quanto
riguarda niente gameplay normali ho
intenzione di fare qualche video su su
motori dreams che secondo me è veramente
ho giocato cinque minuti mi sono morto
ma se non ho mai riso così tanto per un
videogame veramente
dunque cosa di impressionante ragazzi
quindi spero che vi piace anche a voi e
tra poco farà uscire video anche su
quello vediamo aggiornamenti si ho
comprato scribblenauts unlimited che
uscire al limite di meeting on limited
boh non lo so l'ho comprato su steam lo
preacquistato anzi vuol dire che l'ho
comprato ma non ancora uscito uscirà il
15 febbraio 2013
ho avuto la fortuna incredibile a
comprarlo perché l'ho preso in sconto
del 30 per cento mi pare l'ho pagato 14
euro mentre normalmente costa 20
niente lo andrà sicuramente a fare
appena uscirà mi sono messo d'accordo
con dido perché abbiamo intenzione di
fare una coop su scribblenauts unlimited
però è una cosa che
diciamo non siamo sicuri principalmente
per il fatto non sono sicuro io che ci
sia una modalità coop
nel caso ci fosse quasi sicuro che io ti
do la faremo insieme perché diciamo ci
siamo sentiti e niente per portal 2
invece per quelli che ce lo stanno
chiedendo da secoli non lo so ancora
purtroppo per me va bene perché comunque
fare video condivido me piace tantissimo
perché mi sta simpaticissimo quindi
dipende da lui
sperando e pregando che scrive non sun
limited abbia una modalità multiplayer
la faremo a coppie libro sul muso
scribblenauts quando uscirà altre novità
assist daino crisis daino crysis è un
videogame che ho intenzione di fare
penso che lo farò dall'inizio alla fine
anche questo workflow per quanto
riguarda l'oro perché molti di voi mi
seguono per l'orrore state tranquilli
che non lo sono dimenticato
devo fare amnesia 2m cinfor pigs che
uscirà il primo gennaio 2013 quindi tra
pochissimo e penso che lo comprerò al
lancio su steam e niente farò il web può
sicuramente anche di quello
mentre per quanto riguarda faceless
ovvero snejder sousse scendere in coop
la beta mi dovrebbe arrivare a momenti
potrebbe arrivarvi da un giorno
all'altro quindi appena mi arriverà
iniziato a fare video anche su quello è
così vi do un idea di come ok ragazzi
per inaugurare il canale nuovo con
questo primo blog perché quello
iniziaranno considero come primo ditemi
quello che volete
vorrei rispondere a una domanda che
fosse la domanda che mi è stata posta
più frequentemente da quando da quando
sono su youtube
la domanda è la seguente è molto
semplice come mai ti chiami fa vj perché
io ho scelto il nickname
favi j non dico che mi ha fatto la
domanda perché me l'avete fatta in
tantissimi vini ma un minimo senza
esagerare me l'avrebbe fatta almeno in
100 questa domanda come mai mi chiamo fa
vj se il mio nome
mio nome di battesimo è completamente
diverso da fa vj motivo si aspettavano
che mi chiamasse tipo flavio
no per niente mi chiamo lorenzo per
quelli di voi che non lo sanno comunque
ormai tanto il mio profilo la mia
identità è andata a farsi [ __ ] perché
nelle informazioni della pagina di
facebook di fa vj tv e non posso
toglierla perché finché non arrivò a
mille mi piace non me la fa togliere non
so perché ma facebook dai numeri però
tanto oramai l'avete visto tutti amen
mi chiamo lorenzo come mai ho scelto fa
vj come nickname
l'ho voluto dire in un blog perché
rispondere a tutti veramente una cosa
impossibile perché è una storia lunga
molto molto tempo fa vi era un bambino
ingenuo che no vabbè dai stringo perché
sono vabbè quando ero piccolo diciamo
nel lontano 2004 quindi dieci anni fa
avevo tipo 78 anni 78 anni uscì un
videogame che attualmente la rovina di
molti players il videogame in questione
è world of warcraft bird of warcraft è
un gioco di ruolo online che si basa su
completare missioni e salire di livello
per poi fare gruppo con altri tuoi amici
per prendersi pezzi di equipaggiamento
va beh è un gioco di ruolo online
per farla breve è mio padre lo installo
sul suo vecchio pci che io non ho
neanche un mio vicino a voto anni erano
i primi approcci che videogame anzi il
primo approccio con un videogame online
e mio padre lui stallo sul suo vecchio
pci e per giocarci lui mio padre non è
mai stato un videogiocatore così
accanito 15 giocava tipo una volta ogni
settimana per 10 minuti
una volta che non era in casa io ero
piccolo in arrivo una cosa seria mi sono
arrampicato sulla sedia o acceso
computer o avviato guardo fu al caf sono
entrato comunque ho creato questo nuovo
personaggio iniziato a fare missioni
avendo un certo punto mi si avvicina uno
un giocatore chiamato fa vj mi si
avvicina questo qui io mi giro lo guardo
e poi mi rigiro faccio i cazzi miei
perché pensavo fosse un intelligenza
artificiale insomma un personaggio del
gioco
a un certo punto questo che mi scrive
ciao come fa a scrivermi intelligenza
artificiale così gli ho detto minchia lo
hanno fatto benissimo world of warcraft
per chi non conosce guardo work as
quando tu scrivi un messaggio ti appare
sulla testa del personaggio
ad un certo punto ha iniziato a farmi
domande io ho iniziato a fargli domande
avevamo proprio un dialogo reale a un
certo punto mi sono reso conto che
quello effettivamente non era un
intelligenza artificiale ma era un altro
player bara da qualche parte che ne so
in italia e stavo dialogando con lui
tramite un videogioco roba mistica io
non sapevo neanche che si potesse fare
una cosa del genere questa e magia
questa è pazzia anzi a questa guardo
fuori kraft finito questo questo
racconto epico pieno di combattimenti
eccetera
in poche parole mi chiama fa vj perché
uno si chiamava così e gli ho potuto
nickname rivela chance
va bene ragazzi per quelli nuovi che non
lo sanno in ogni blog io sono solito a
rispondere alle vostre domande domande
che vi potete lasciare qui sotto nel
videoblog come commento e le domande che
ritengo opportune io risponderò
risponderò nel prossimo blog the screen
eroe risponderò
[Musica]
ok ragazzi dopo questa questa pessima
figura
vi saluto se vi è piaciuto video
lasciato mi piace vi ricordo di
iscrivervi alla pagina facebook di fa
vige tv che trovate nella descrizione di
ogni video che metto nella quale potete
lasciarmi traquillamente una domanda
oppure potete lasciarmela sul mio
profilo personale di facebook che
trovate le informazioni della pagina di
parigi e tv tanto ormai la mid entità
andata [ __ ] e niente se vi è piaciuto
video lasciato un commento mi piace e ci
vediamo al prossimo video probabilmente
su penombra overture bella ragazzi